wives submit to your own husbands as to the Lord. For the husband is the head of the wife,
even as Christ is the head of the church, his body and is himself its savior. Now, as the
church submits to Christ, so also wives should submit in everything to their husbands. Husbands
love your wives as Christ loved the church and gave himself up for her. That he might
sanctify her having cleansed her by the washing of the water with the word, so that he might
present the church to himself in splendor without spot or wrinkle or any such thing that she
might be holy and without blemish. In the same way, husbands should love their wives
as their own bodies. He who loves his wife loves himself, for no one ever hated his own
flesh but nourishes and cherishes it just as Christ does the church, because we are
members of his body. Therefore, a man shall leave his father and mother and hold fast to
his wife and the two shall become one flesh. This mystery is profound and I am saying that
it refers to Christ and the church. However, let each one of you love his wife as himself
and let the wife see that she respects her husband. This is the word of the Lord.
Well, good morning. As Brandon said, my name is Matt Toodle. And I feel blessed to have
the opportunity to be here. I'm thankful for this opportunity and somewhat nervous. So,
I ask that you bear with me. Also, a special thanks to Mary and the worship team for
truly leading us in the gospel. I mean, what we just sang, we essentially could say amen
and go home and we just heard an incredible sermon just in the gospel truths that they
are so faithful to wash over us weekend and week out. So, very thankful for that. If
you would, bow with me in prayer and then we'll get started. Father, we thank you
so much for the gift of community. We thank you for the gift that is the local body,
your bride, the church. So, we asked this morning that you would open the eyes of our
heart so that we could see, savor, believe and be transformed by wondrous things from
your word. Not from the words of this sinful man who's nervous or not from the words
of this sinful man who's focused on what others think, but truly by the power of your
word would you open our eyes and transform us for your glory and in your name we pray.
Amen. So, it was a cold December morning in 1998, a Monday morning. My suit was all
pressed. I had the short, close-cropped militaristic haircut and I reported to the Knoxville
Police Academy for the beginning of what was going to be six months of training as part
of class 98 Bravo. So, I walked into the, walked into the academy area myself and about
50 others and we were greeted by the mayor of Knoxville, the chief of police, the command
staff, city council, everybody there to welcome us and tell us how proud we should be to be
there, how honored we should be, how many people had applied for this and how many got
selected and boy they propped us up. And then they, out of the goodness of their heart
gave us a lengthy lunch, said hey, cut out early, go have a good lunch and be back at
one o'clock. And when we walked in at one o'clock it was as if a switch had been
flipped. All of that goodness and great and how wonderful you are had completely
changed and we were suddenly scum of the earth, the worst people in the world. We
really didn't want to be there. We should quit right now. We were worthless and we
were in the floor in what's called the front-leaning rest which is the up position
of a push-up and we were there over and over again as we were screamed at and
told to recite hundreds of pages of general orders that we had just been provided
with. And then as a break in the front-leaning rest we got to go outside and run two
or three miles in our suit and dress shoes. And we got a break from that to do
knuckle push-ups outside. But all the while through that because I had had just
an inkling of an idea that this was happening. So I had decided I needed a
couple of ideas of hope to hold on to. So throughout all of that, what was
considered Hell Week and even the following week, I held on to two pieces of hope.
Number one was I knew no matter how bad it got they would not kill me.
Number two, I knew that no matter how long the day went I was going home at
the end of the day. And those two pieces of hope sustained me through that but it
really could have crushed me. That whole experience could have crushed me and I
saw it crush other people. There were people who quit that day, the next day
following days we went from 50 to about 30 people after a couple of weeks.
And I tell that story because the extreme importance of hope, the passage
we're talking about this morning outside of context has the very real potential
of crushing you. At least I know it would me. I know the instructions given in
this outside of context and without hope would be crushing. And so that's the
beauty of going verse by verse through books of the Bible. See we didn't just
land here this morning. This isn't a random Valentine's Day weekend passage on
marriage. Although we probably have all heard that. We've probably all heard this
passage in one form or another whether it's at a men's conference, women's
conference, marriage retreat or just a topical sermon. We've heard this
preached to fit a particular theme. And so I think it's very important for
us to remember as we've gone through and been going through the book of
Ephesians the first three chapters that we looked at laid the foundation
the essential building blocks the hope that will fuel the rest of the book of
Ephesians. We got to remember this was a letter. This was intended to be read
processed as a whole in one sitting essentially each portion in context and
in relation to the rest of the letter. And so since it's been several weeks
since we've covered these truths before we go any further I want to remind us of
what that hope is. What are the truths that will fuel our ability to to truly
walk in a manner worthy of the calling in which we have been called. Because if
if you've placed your faith and hope and trust in the finished work of Jesus
Christ, then the following that I'm going to read are true of you right now.
Not not eventually not when you finally clean yourself up or you fix that that one
thing. But right now. So on the authority of Scripture in context of the rest of
the book of the first three chapters of the book of Ephesians right now you are
a saint. You are blessed in Christ with every spiritual blessing in the
heavenly places. You were chosen before the foundation of the world. You
were chosen to be holy and blameless before the Lord. In love God the Father
predestined you to be adopted as a son through Jesus. You are blessed with
glorious grace. You have redemption through Jesus's blood. Your trespasses
past present and future are forgiven forever. The riches of his glorious
grace are lavished upon you right now. You have obtained an inheritance in Jesus.
You are sealed with the Holy Spirit who is the guarantee of your inheritance. He
has a measurably great power towards you. Even though you were once dead doing
thinking, desiring, following and dwelling on a lot of evil things because of
God's great love for you, he made you alive. He saved you by grace. He raised
you up and seated you in the heavenly places. And why did he do that? To show
you the immeasurable riches of his grace and kindness. Period. He gave you the
gift of faith to trust him. You didn't muster that up. It's not your
works. You didn't earn it so you can't lose it. You were created for good works.
Once he prepared for you beforehand. Ones like we're going to talk about this
morning. Although you were once far off, you have been brought near to God
because of Jesus's work. He is your peace. You are reconciled to God. You
have continual access to the creator and sustainer of the universe. Through Jesus
you have boldness and access to God the Father. You are rooted and grounded in
love. You, Saint, are loved by Jesus in a way that surpasses knowledge, a
love that is immeasurably wide, high and deep. And because of the power
currently at work within you, he is able to do far more abundantly than you
could ever ask or think. This church is the word of the Lord. And so based on
those and many other foundational truths from the first three chapters of
Ephesians, we're going to dive in and look at a profound mystery. So if you
have your Bible, look with me in Ephesians 5 chapter, or chapter 5
beginning in verse 22. Wives submit to your own husbands as to the Lord, for
the husband is the head of the wife, even as Christ is the head of the
church, his body, and is himself its savior. Now as the church submits to
Christ, so also wives should submit in everything to their husbands. And I
just want to say at the outset, I believe there are very few passages in
Scripture that have been taken out of context more than this one. And
this verse taken out of context has been used to cause real damage, pain, and
even abuse. And we in the church, I believe, need to acknowledge that. So
I just want to say on the authority of God's Word within the context of the
book of Ephesians, within the context of the New Testament and the
entirety of Scripture, this passage absolutely does not put the wife in
an inferior, subservient, or any type of demeaning position to blindly say yes to
whatever her husband demands. This is not the context or intent of this passage.
Again, we have to remember, this is a letter. It didn't originally have
chapters and verses and headings. And in fact, the verse we covered last
week, verse 21 that says submit to one another, submitting to one another out of
reverence for Christ, that verse in some translations is actually included under
this heading or this passage of marriage in the home. In the ESV and other
translations, it's included in the previous heading. But again, we've got
to remember that headings are not part of God's Word. And I believe from the
context of Ephesians, Paul is continuing his teaching in one thought from our
mutual submission to each other, to our mutual submission to other members of the
body of Christ, to more of a detailed look at the family. So yes, within the
context of marriage, we are called to submit to one another out of reverence
for Christ. There is a component of mutual submission there. And at the same
time, Paul is showing that God has ordained a leadership model within the
home with the husband as the head, loving his wife as Christ loved the church
and calling wives to submit to their husbands as to the Lord. So what does
that mean? I'm going to borrow a couple of definitions from John Piper that as I've
studied this text within the context of Ephesians, within the context of the
rest of Scripture, including parallel passages, I found these definitions to
be incredibly helpful, biblically accurate and even beautiful. So listen to
how Piper defines headship and submission. Headship is the divine calling of a
husband to take primary responsibility for Christ-like servant leadership,
protection and provision in the home. Submission is the divine calling of a
wife to honor and affirm her husband's leadership and help carry it through
according to her gifts. Let me read those again. Headship is the divine calling of
a husband to take primary responsibility for Christ-like servant leadership,
protection and provision in the home. Christ-like servant leadership. Nothing
about domineering, demeaning or demanding my way or the highway. It's a
dying to self-servant form of leadership, but we'll get to more on that in a little
bit. Back to submission. Submission is the divine calling of a wife to honor and
affirm her husband's leadership and help carry it through according to her gifts.
Notice help carry it through according to her gifts. Nothing about
subjugation, nothing about sitting quietly in the corner and watching, all about
using her God-given gifts to honor and affirm her husband's leadership and
being an active part and carrying it through, an active part. So with that
definition of submission in mind, wives submit to your own husbands as to the
Lord. That little piece as to the Lord, that can be somewhat confusing. What that
doesn't mean is as if your husband is the Lord. That does not mean with the same
allegiance that you submit to Christ. This is more about your attitude and
approach to your role as wife. In fact, in a parallel passage in Colossians
3, Paul uses the term as his fitting in the Lord. You're submitting as an act of
obedience and even worship to the Lord. So it's almost as if you're saying as you
submit to your husband, you are submitting to the Lord. And then Paul goes on to
give us the why. For the husband is the head of the wife, even as Christ is the
head of the church, his body, and is himself its savior. Now as the church
submits to Christ, also wives should submit in everything to their husbands. So
the husband is the head of the wife. Again, expressing that headship in
servant leadership. And we see that parallel, that parallel to the mystery
of marriage, of our earthly marriage reflecting the relationship or marriage
between Christ and his bride, the church. New Testament scholar Grant Osborn
puts it this way. Christ's view of headship is always much broader than
mere authority. In his own service as head of the body, the church, he
strengthens, builds up, watches over, sustains, and in every way functions for
its good. And then it's explicitly stated in those verses, he Christ is
himself the church's savior. I think now is a good time to remind us of
something we know, but maybe we don't always practice. Husbands, we are
not our wives' saviors. We never will be. Wives, your husband is not your
savior. He never will be. And internally we may laugh and say, okay, yeah, thank
you Captain Obvious, because we know that intellectually. But how many times do
we practically look at our spouse and expect them to be our savior? Or how
many times have we felt that internal pressure to be the savior? We're not
each other's saviors. But we can take some clues from how the church submits to
Christ and apply them to how wives should submit to their husbands. How
does the church submit to Christ? Silently in bondage, lacking personality
or freedom? Absolutely not. That's why I'm so drawn to Piper's quote, honor and
affirm her husband's leadership and help carry it through according to her gifts.
We the church, the body of Christ submit to Jesus our head and as we do that
we actively pursue his mission. We use our unique gifts and diverse
abilities to do that. In fact, at Trinity, a Bible believing gospel preaching church,
we submit to Christ's mission. We submit to him in ways that may look very
differently than other Bible believing churches. Just down the road,
Gardendale First Baptist, another Bible believing gospel preaching church
submits to Christ and his mission in ways that may look very differently than
us. And there's countless other examples. So wives, this is not about you being a
cookie cut version of what past experiences or misguided society tells you
a wife should look like. This is all about you using your God given gifts,
your unique print personality and specific abilities and calling to
willingly, joyfully submit to your husband's servant leadership. And
to help carry it out as an act of obedience, submission and even worship to
Jesus. Now for the easy part, husbands love your wives as Christ loved the
church. Guess we can just pray and invite the band to come back up and
just know in all seriousness, this passage can so easily be misinterpreted,
misunderstood due to an incorrect emphasis on the word submit. And let's be
honest, when we hear that word, it can cause some folks to bristle. And I
think that's because it's not understood in the context that we just talked
about. But what we have to understand and grasp is the basis and focus of
this passage is not on control or submission. The basis of this passage is
love. And it should definitely be noted that Paul spends over twice the amount
of time and words and space devoted to addressing the husband's obligation to
love as he does to the wife's obligation to submit. So let's dive back
into verse 25. Husbands love your wives as Christ loved the church and
gave himself up for her that he might sanctify her, having cleansed her by
the washing of water with the word so that he might present the church to
himself in splendor without spot or wrinkle or any such thing. That she
might be holy and without blemish. In the same way, husbands should love
their wives as their own bodies. He who loves his wife loves himself
for no one ever hated his own flesh but nourishes and cherishes it just as
Christ does the church because we are members of his body. Therefore a
man shall leave his mother and father and hold fast to his wife and the
two shall become one flesh. As Christ loved the church and gave
himself up for her, husbands that's how we are supposed to love. And
so that begs the question, how does Christ love the church? Well,
obviously it's immeasurable ways but for the sake of this morning and this
passage we're going to look at four ways described in this text of how
Jesus loves us and how we husbands are called to love our wives. First,
Christ's love is a sacrificial love. It's never selfish. Christ doesn't
love the church. He doesn't love you and me because of or in light of
what we can do for him. His love is not based on our actions or our
inactions and in no way is his disposition toward us dependent on us
or what we can do. Christ gave himself up for the church, for you
and for me. So husbands, we're called to sacrifice our wants, our
desires, our comfort and even our well-being for our wives. We are
called to servant leadership. In Mark 10, Jesus proclaims that he came
not to be served but to serve and to give his life as a ransom for
many. That should define our leadership, to serve our wives and
to give every aspect of our lives for them. Second, if you look at the
text, Christ's love for us is a purifying love. He washed us
wider than snow. We as husbands are called to be an active part in
meeting our wives' physical, emotional and spiritual needs. Just as Jesus
cleansed us by the washing of the water through the blood, we should
be bathing our wives in the truths of the gospel. We're called to be a
very active part in their sanctification and we should be bathing
them in prayer. There's no doubt an all-out assault on the identities of
women today. Some studies suggest that we're exposed to between 4,000
and 10,000 advertisements and media images daily all designed to create
some sort of definition on our identity. And men, we are called to
drown out those voices and images, revealing our wives as the true brides
of Christ that they are, reminding them early and often about what is true
about their identities in Christ and what voice really matters.
Continuing on, third, Christ's love for us is a caring love. He
nourishes and cherishes us. We're called to love our wives as our own
bodies. And when I read that, it's kind of like holding a mirror up in
front of my face because it forces me to truly consider how often I'm
so consumed with my own body, my wants, my comfort, my convenience,
my needs and my pleasure. And we as husbands are called to lay all of
those down and be consumed with our wives' needs. We're called to nourish
and cherish them. And fourth and finally Christ's love is unbreakable.
We are members of his body. He is our head and we are his body.
And then this Paul points back to the creation story in Genesis 2 with
this verse that we so often quote at weddings.
Therefore, and he's saying, therefore, based on the fact that she is bone of
my bone and flesh of my flesh, therefore a man shall leave his father
and mother and hold fast to his wife and the two shall become one flesh.
In this we're forsaking all others and we're holding fast to.
We're clinging to. We're grafted into our wives. We truly become one with them.
And it's part of our loving them as Christ loved the church that we ensure
our wives know this. We are one with them. Our love is unbreakable.
And so just some final thoughts on this section.
These instructions that we just looked at from Paul.
They're intended to and meant to work in harmony as we've seen to paint a picture
of Christ and his bride. So the ideal is for the wife to gladly submit
to her self-sacrificing husband.
But I think we need to notice the very important, very telling
and I believe very intentional absence of one particular word.
As hard as I looked and I checked and double checked, I could not find the word
if in that passage. Meaning wives submit to your husband's if.
Or husbands love your wives as Christ loved the church if.
That word is not there. Husbands, we know that Jesus's love, care and sacrifice
for us, his bride is in no way contingent on our behavior or our submission to him.
And our servant leadership and love should model that.
And while wives you absolutely should never submit to or go along with anything
sinful, harmful or abusive period.
But absent that you are still called to gladly submit as to the Lord.
Even when your husband doesn't model the leadership and love that we talked about this morning.
And so now for the hidden gem in this passage is verse 32.
This mystery is profound and I am saying that it refers to Christ and the church.
Husbands, we individually are not the focus of this passage.
Our leadership of our wives is not the star of the show.
Wives, your submission is not the primary focus of this passage.
And single people, you are in no way left out of this passage.
The primary focus, the main theme of this passage is Jesus's love for you and for me, the church, his bride.
He's chosen our marriages as a metaphor, a sign, an image to point to how he interacts and cares for and loves us, his bride.
And how he calls us as a church to submit to him in love.
English theologian Jeffrey Bromley put it this way.
As God made man in his own image, so he made earthly marriage in the image of his own eternal marriage with his people.
We all, those of us who have put our faith and trust in the finished work of Jesus are the bride of Christ.
He gave himself up for you and me.
Why?
To sanctify us, to clean us up, to take us in and wash away the ugly stains of sin for good forever.
And he did all of that so he might present us, his church, his bride to himself in splendor without spot or wrinkle.
And so we will be holy and without blemish.
That's the main point of this passage.
That's the profound mystery.
And he uses us, fallen, broken, and at times selfish and self-serving husbands and wives to image that to the world.
But in closing, Paul under the inspiration of the Holy Spirit knew that there would be people like me reading this passage.
Because my tendency would be to say, okay, thank God, this is just a metaphor of Christ in the church, so I'm off the hook.
So he closes with verse 33.
However, let each of you love his wife as himself and let the wife see that she respects her husband.
That's the however.
That's Paul pointing back and reminding us of everything about Jesus' love and purifying of his bride.
That is the main point.
But at the same time, we are called to be images.
We are his ambassadors.
We are called to that loving servant leadership and to that loving, godly submission to that leadership.
So no, we're not off the hook.
So I kind of wrestled with how to wrap up and kind of figured, okay, let's do a few practical but not all-encompassing suggestions.
And I say this with the caveat of stuff like this is really best dealt with in the context of a home group.
I'm going to use this as an opportunity to pitch home groups.
If you have not had a chance to plug into one or join one, I would highly recommend it.
I say that being not a staff member, not even a home group leader, just the beneficiary of home groups.
Since Jennifer and I have been plugged into one, we have seen opportunities to share struggles, successes,
everything together in a group and really process that together.
And it's been a tremendous grace for us.
So I really think that's the context where we should walk through these things.
But just a couple of practical suggestions.
Wives, it means the world to us when you affirm our leadership.
I mean, just so you know, we don't always feel like we're nailing it.
Regardless of what we may look like, we really do feel the weight of what it means to love you as Christ loves the church and what that means.
And we actually frequently question how we're doing it that.
And so your affirmation can be like wind in our sails.
Submitting to our leadership doesn't mean never questioning ideas or thoughts.
Remember, that's where the analogy of Christ in the church breaks down.
Christ is sovereign and all wise and we are not.
We will definitely have some boneheaded ideas and thoughts.
And submitting does not look like you letting us create a dumpster fire.
We got to remember in that definition about using your gifts.
I would submit submitting means graciously, gently, humbly using your God given gifts to speak wisdom into the situation while still affirming our leadership and speaking life into us.
I can think of countless examples where Jennifer has done that for me even recently as I began processing things within my career.
Sometimes I can be blinded by ambition and think, hey, this might be the best thing to do.
And she gently, lovingly reminds me of what's true, reminds me of some truth in that, but also says along the lines, if you really feel called to that, let's definitely process it.
It's never in a sense of, okay, idiot, you know, you've been there, done that, when are you going to get it?
It's always in that context.
And then a disclaimer, I kind of feel like a fat guy telling you how to lose weight with this part, but recognizing my own imperfection is not an excuse not to strive for it.
So husbands, our wives, our kids, our church needs our self-sacrificing servant leadership.
We don't always have to have the answer, nor do we always have to know how to fix it, but we are called to lay down our wants and needs for the good of our wives.
We're called to spiritually lead them, even if it means stepping outside of our comfort zones.
We need to do battle daily for our wives so they can recognize themselves as our cherished, beautiful, secure brides, and more importantly, the bride of Christ.
So how do we do this?
What's the trick?
When faced with instructions like this, we typically have a couple of choices.
We can pull ourselves up by the bootstraps and white-knuckle it and resolve to do better and be better and make all these changes in our own strength.
Or we can dwell on, rest in, and hope in the truths from the first three chapters of Ephesians and what we just covered about Jesus' love for us, all the while keeping our eyes on Jesus.
In John 15, as Jesus is giving some of his final instructions to his disciples on how to do what he's called them and us to do,
he said, I am the vine. You are the branches. Whoever abides in me and I in him, he it is that bears much fruit. For apart from me, you can do nothing.
So let me kind of put that into context of this morning. You can do nothing.
Wives, apart from abiding in Jesus, you cannot submit in a godly way to your husband.
Husbands, apart from abiding in Jesus, you cannot love your wife as Christ loves the church. You can do nothing.
So I would submit the best thing you can do for your marriage is have a better lover. Jesus, the lover of your soul.
And if you abide in Jesus, you will bear much fruit.
Fruit like love, joy, peace, patience, goodness, kindness, gentleness, and self-control.
That sounds a lot like godly submission and loving servant leadership. Let's pray.
Father, again, we thank you for your word. Pray that you would use your words to change, to change us, to change our hearts.
We thank you that you have given us the recipe for that, that we might abide in you, that we might turn our eyes to Jesus and put our faith, hope, and confidence in the finished work of Jesus.
Would you lead us in that? Would you give us opportunities to have real conversations surrounding this with our spouses and with our home groups?
Of what it truly means to lovingly and submit in a godly way and to model Christ-like servant leadership to our wives.
And it's for your name and your glory, Jesus. We pray in Jesus' name. Amen.